there were like 200 people in the room
just standing and also like my parents
were there
that's so obvious millie bobby brown is
such an incredible hard-working actor so
naturally there are going to be plenty
of scenes where she has to overcome some
super awkward emotionally intense
situations in order to get the job done
number one
this definitely didn't go according to
plan now we all know vecna is the
horrifying big bad of hawkins jamie
campbell bauer does an incredible job
playing the villain so great that he's
bringing his co-stars to tears during
rehearsals
jamie had to give me a hug because i
couldn't do the scene in an interview
with variety he talks about how he may
have traumatized our brave heroine they
brought her up into a position where
she's bound i walked up to her and she
burst into tears she wouldn't look at me
and she was visibly just disgusted by
the whole thing
number two not one of eleven's greatest
moments
if you've caught up on season four you
know which scene we're talking about
it's pretty hard to forget when eleven
was getting bullied by angela and her
gaggle of mean girls millie bobby brown
had a really hard time disassociating
from those feelings of difficult pain
and embarrassment because she herself
used to get bullied like that she opens
up a bit about this in an interview with
sci-fi wire i remember about 50 people
laughing at me and pointing at me i
remember feeling super distressed and
really sad noah cried which is insane i
don't know if anyone knows that number
three
the only embarrassing thing about this
is that we'll actually miss dr brenner
this was also one of millie's least
favorite scenes to shoot in all of
season four so we couldn't help but
include it matthew modine is very close
with millie bobby brown in real life
we've walked to set from base camp it's
45 minutes he truly is like a father
figure tour so when his character dies
at the end of season 4 it was a solemn
day for the pair we walked because we
were really sad that day it was a very
sad day for us both number four this
seems to be a theme when filming intense
television throughout the entirety of
season 3 millie bobby brown lost her
voice due to all the screaming she had
to do during scenes with daker
montgomery in an interview with gma news
she opens up about the predicament i
lost my voice five times
five different times throughout the
eight months of filming i have to go
back into the avr room and start
screaming number five hilarious and
awkward improv a major season three
moment happens in the hawkins
supermarket when mike tries to tell 11
that he loves her most of this scene was
improvised the duffer brothers gave finn
wolfhard a lot of freedom in this
endearing monologue millie bobby brown's
reaction was totally genuine she was
mostly just trying not to laugh because
of how awkward finn was being
like i've never felt like this you know
with anyone before number six
not only for millie bobby brown most of
the cast had their first kiss on the set
of stranger things after looking back on
the scene finn was probably more
embarrassed than millie on this one
this was definitely a notable moment for
the pair and it's gotten a lot easier
since their first time locking lips and
the duffer saw that they're like perfect
he doesn't know how to kiss that's great
number seven speaking of million finn's
first kiss did you know that finn
wolfhard cued her in for it the snowball
dance was home to a couple of iconic
first kisses but sadie sink and caleb
mclaughlin's kiss took about 10 takes
while million finns only took two
there was a lot of pressure on the kids
as tons of people had eyes on them even
giving them awkward high fives and
rounds of applause after it was done to
temper this awkwardness finn told millie
very quietly without moving his lips too
much he was like okay i'm coming in
right as he was about to lean in number
eight yes we're talking about farts
millie bobby brown wasn't the one doing
it but she did have to endure a bus that
was hot boxed with one of her co-stars
farts the duffer brothers shared the
experience in an article for
entertainment weekly millie was getting
more and more frustrated with her male
co-stars case in point we're shooting a
scene in an abandoned bus and one of the
boys decides to fart more than once it
became so toxic in the bus that the crew
had to temporarily evacuate
number nine we still don't know where it
came from as far as we know millie bobby
brown is always professional even from
the young age of 11 but throughout all
these years of filming she was still a
kid and sometimes kids show up to set
covered in glitter the duffer brothers
talked twin pr about the mysterious
glitter that delayed shooting for almost
an hour one day she showed up on set and
she was just covered head to toe in
glitter and she's like i don't know
where this glitter came from number 10 a
little embarrassing a little gross
millie doesn't typically shy away from
difficult scenes or stunts but we did
find out she's not so keen on being
strapped into a harness for a difficult
season 3 scene she was stuck spinning
around in the upside down due to the
fact that she was doing her own stunt
work that day the fear and discomfort on
her face were 100 real i was just
constantly going upside down which kind
of sucked i threw up after number 11.
speaking of dizzy one of millie bobby
brown's most difficult scenes to shoot
in season 3 had her upside down and
screaming at the top of her lungs she
talks about it in an interview with
entertainment weekly i'd say the hardest
thing for me to do is when the monster
grabs my leg because i was lifted up
into the air and i have to scream upside
down which was definitely a lot
being held upside down screaming in
front of all of your friends while
trying to stay in character kind of a
funny moment to imagine
number 12. also known as 11's signature
hairstyle one thing millie bobby brown
learned from playing 11 was how to be
kind and care for others mostly because
of how much hate she endured simply
because of her haircut in an interview
with w magazine she talks about her
struggles with the public after shaving
her head people would laugh at me
without knowing whether i was or wasn't
sick it was hurtful remember the times
where i would like walk on the street
and everybody just sort of freak with
the no hair number 13. typically a great
meal for any occasion we all remember
eleven's introduction she sneaks into
benny's restaurant and steals some fries
from the kitchen eventually he ends up
cooking her a burger in order to ask her
a few questions apparently that scene
was one of millie's least favorites to
shoot at the time because all of the
food was cold naturally she talked to
bon appetit about this unfortunate
culinary experience i had to stuff my
face with cold fries they were so greasy
i had like three burgers and i'd put
them in my mouth and they were cold i
was like are you kidding me she had a
cup beside her and after she would
mutter her line
11
she would spit the burger into a cup and
come back up number 14 not that anyone's
counting one of the most awkward
curveballs that millie had to manage
when starting out on stranger things was
learning how to act without lines i'll
give this back
and you can have as much as you want all
right maybe even some ice cream but you
got to answer a few my questions first
all right at first she definitely felt a
bit self-conscious just utilizing her
facial expressions to convey her
character's emotions
but she obviously did get the hang of it
later on number 15 this definitely makes
for an awkward crying scene in this
unforgettable season 1 episode mike
lucas and dustin ask 11 to lead them to
will they end up following some
emergency vehicles to a quarry where the
body was found on paper this absolutely
reads like an emotional scene but due to
freezing weather millie really struggled
with it so my tears were freezing and me
and mike were like
we just
couldn't cry
so we've got some major embarrassment
some touching heartfelt moments and
quite a bit of straight up genuine
terror looking at you vechna which one
of these moments is your favorite
you